good morning believe nation today's
message is do what you love over to you
Seth MacFarlane what were you like as a
child I I was a combination of reclusive
and obsessed with what I wanted to do
when I was 2 I want I was sitting in
front of the TV drawing Fred
Flintstone's and woody woodpecker's and
at age 7 I'm running around like a crazy
person doing voices but at the same time
I would try to make animated films and
try to figure out exactly how that art
form worked when did you do your first
cartoon how old were you and what was it
I was in seventh grade it was called
space pirates it was terrible so doing
what you love following your passion is
the most consistent message that comes
from the famous entrepreneurs innovators
artists musicians that we've had
profiled on this channel it anybody
who's at the top of their game says you
need to love what you're doing what I
find really interesting about this clip
is two things one if you don't know what
you're what you love doing if you don't
know what your passion is there may be
precursors earlier on in your life to
figure it out so for him he loved
drawing right he loved that aspect of
his life for me I never thought I was
gonna be an entrepreneur but I had five
years old
sold pictures door-to-door that I had
painted with my three-year-old little
sister going through school
I sold baseball cards to my friends and
went to Florida they get autographs of
the baseball players and then brought
them back here and sold them at a
premium
I joined Junior Achievement and won all
kinds of awards and being part of their
company program which is after-school
program and all of this stuff but I had
all these aren't feral tendencies but I
still thought I was gonna be an
investment banker of some kind or
consultant of some kind I was still what
I thought I was gonna be cuz I didn't
have as much exposure right my
environment was safe corporate job
nobody my family was an entrepreneur
nobody around me was an entrepreneur and
so it doesn't surprise me or anybody
that I went down that path
there were signs there before I just
didn't listen to them and the people
around me I guess couldn't point them
out for me either so if you're still
struggling to find out what it is that
you love doing there may be some signs
you can look to what did you love doing
when you were five or ten or fifteen or
twenty or whatever it is there may be
some clues are for you
the second thing that I loved about it
was that he sucked at the start right
his first thing was terrible so you can
expect to suck at the start of whatever
you do you can love it you have an
inclination to want to do it you want to
go out more and uncover a little bit
more about it but you may suck in the
process right don't expect your first
thing to be amazing
what's way more important is the passion
that you're drawn to it that you want to
go and do it again when I first started
salsa dancing I sucked I walked into a
class and I was terrible I actually went
to another school as well I took two
classes to different schools at the same
time to try to get better because I suck
so badly at the start didn't want to let
down the people in my class so I had
extra practice time you expect the suck
but I loved it and I wanted to go back
and do more and get better writing with
time and with practice and with patience
my skills improved and so just because
you're not good at something if you feel
drawn to it
go it and try it and if you like it do
it again and do it again and do it again
don't put so much pressure but this has
to be the thing that you love because if
I did that I would never completed salsa
would have never kept going on because
on paper it looks terrible that I'm I'm
tall
I take big steps I don't know Spanish
I'm learning as an adult you know all of
these things are potentially holding me
back and put the people who've been
dancing for a lot longer but I was able
to quickly pass them because I love
doing it and that's what's really
important so the question of the day
today is I'm curious
were there signs earlier in your life
that this is what you're supposed to be
doing I'm curious what those signs may
or may not have been leave it down in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tristan Becnel Tristan
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys for watching I believe in you I
hope
continue to belief in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
inter